what percentage of conspiracy theories
end up being true
oh gosh that's an interesting question
what per like you have to realize
all this alien stuff we're talking about
right now like it's normal try doing
that 20 years ago
try doing that 10 years ago all this
stuff that we're talking about aliens
today try doing that 10 years ago
all this stuff about jfk everybody was
you know
okay okay wait i have an opinion on that
the conspiracy theory
in this country the conspiracy theorists
in this country are toxic
i mean i just i gotta lay that out there
but part of the reason conspiracies are
so
hot and prevalent is because of what we
were talking about censorship
if you don't get both sides of the story
you're gonna start making stuff up and
you're going to believe whatever you're
told about the other side of the story
and that's what a conspiracy theory is
you believe what you're told
what's a conspiracy theory to you define
conspiracy theory
it is a mistruth that populates
so what's the difference between a
conspiracy theory and an opinion
the difference well a conspiracy theory
is meant to
influence your thinking your your
opinion is just
definition pull one is meant to
influence other people's thinking and
the other is a reflection of your own
thinking
your opinion that's a personal thing
yeah but your opinion you share with
others that's a form of trying to
influence another person right so go
definition conspiracy theory
prior prior to social media you just put
conspiracy conspiracy
theory and then go pull up opinion let's
see what it is
a belief that some secret but
influential organization is responsible
for an event or phenomenon
so you don't
but you can't say that i don't even know
what q anon is you can't say that
somebody could say that you if you say
that's fox news that's cnn cnn said
russia was a
you know real thing for three years and
you come out of that series on the other
side that was it would you qualify that
as a conspiracy theory
but i don't think most people think cnn
or fox
are news channels oh you'll be surprised
what are you talking about
we may not we may not we do you look at
cnn and fox as a propaganda machine
i look at cnn and fox as having agendas
and that's not
news okay i do too so what is news to
you
truly both sides of the story telling
both sides of the story
it's what the new york times used to be
it's what the wall street journal
used to be so you still don't put ws as
news today
wsj um has become
a little bit more left-leaning than you
would think
but again my gauge is pure and simple if
you're going to put joe q
out there in his opinion you're going to
say but this person maintains that
dot dot dot you have to give both sides
or it's not
news then it's then it's opinion a
belief that
some covert but inflational organization
is responsible for circumstance or event
how do you not believe that i mean
that's a very uh realistic uh
thing that has been happening for
centuries that's not i know type in
opinion definition kai
opinion definition definition of opinion
what no no no keep this keep this go to
a new link go no go to completely
conspiracy theories are why john mcafee
went nuts i totally agree with you
i totally agree with you by the way you
start believing when i sat down with
alex jones and we talked i'm like what
are you doing i said you just
you know feeding some stuff that's a
little too much and you're doing it over
and over and over again
so a view or judgment formed about
something
not necessarily based on fact or
knowledge which all of us have them
right we all have opinions right right
but so so now what we
what we categorically figured out based
on what our friends at google say is a
conspiracy theory
is when somebody believes that a
powerful
organization or institution is covering
something up
which is obviously which is obviously
never happening
is the ultimate conspiracy theory i mean
i have friends
meaning it's not real meaning doesn't
exist but i have friends who have gone
yeah around you you're saying q and
around the band correct okay yeah
well i hope it doesn't exist i mean
aren't they no i hope well me and all my
democrat friends we all just you know
eat baby blood
no no no no no that's what we do that's
the thing
if if you frame a conspiracy theory as
being
me and all my democratic friends then
then you
give credence to it you can't be not
dead naive buddy you cannot believe that
you give creatures you know that was a
joke guys
what are we talking about of course no
you're making a joke but it's also
that undermines the fact that there may
be some credence
to a story that's being told i'm not
saying it is or not that's not what i'm
saying
by the way that whole story it's a crazy
story but guess what
there's a group of people that believe
some powerful people may be doing
something like that so what are you
going to do
so do you just sit there and you say i
don't know about that i don't know
we shouldn't look into it so what is
what is what is journalism so let's just
say
i'm a journalist i work at cnn fox nbc
abc cbs whatever it is
and the story pops on my uh uh table and
say hey
here's a note i just want you to look
into this here's what's potentially
taking place at this
catholic church should i look into it or
no it's a conspiracy theory
because catholic church is a very
powerful institution organization that's
been hiding something for a while
i shouldn't look into it did you not see
the movie with what was the guy's name
the davinci code not the da vinci code
the other guy that was recently done a
couple of years ago what is the guy's
name that was played the the founder
he was the uh what is the guys that
played founder ray kroc's guy
michael keaton the news newsman
yes yes yes it was a great movie about
it with rachel mcadams himself and
they're trying to kind of figure out the
cover
okay and then they find all these should
we not look it up
should we not hold the government over
should we look up so
this goes back to your initial question
what percentage of conspiracy theories
are
actually true did you have a number that
you had
probably a very small percentage less
than ten percent
that's why that's why we look back and
we go wow woodward and bernstein
all the president's men yeah erin
brockovich that's investigative
journalism because they got both sides
of the story and they didn't stop
digging until they got on both sides of
the story or not
okay that's the problem very few outlets
so what happens if we're not getting
both sides of the story what that makes
it is
everything becomes conspiracy theory
unless if both sides are willing to do
some digging
but we're not willing to do the digging
because god forbid it's true
look at hollywood who were they afraid
of digging for the longest time
who was hollywood afraid of digging for
longest time who were they who were they
afraid of oh my gosh we all know what's
going on with guys we can't say harvey
weinstein
yeah you couldn't say anything yeah you
couldn't say anything yeah
there's still another guy that's up dude
and people are afraid of saying things
you know i had a guy who was a
extremely good looking guy okay who
worked at ballets with me
extremely good looking guy he had the
green eyes he was six
three he had that little rougher on the
edge's personality he was doing movies
we did a couple of things together
no not like adam no he had a different
personality
that guy adam's not rough around the
edges adam's actually sweet this guy was
like
no no he's he's got the look but he's
not he's not thank you guys
yeah appreciate it so so sean sean this
guy let's call him sean his name is sean
so let's pretend his name is his name is
shot he says to me
he says to me he says uh i said so how
come you didn't personal hollywood he
said i don't want to talk about it tell
me how come you don't personal hollywood
he says
because you're in hollywood at the time
you're saying that you're in i'm trying
you know
anyway so he says let me tell you what
happened to me he said this is when i
said no he says one day i'm invited to a
party
with uh uh david uh what is the david
something what is the big producer big
uh hollywood name
uh uh is it giffen is it g davidson
david geffen
anyway something like that he says i'm
invited to this party now he tells me
the story says
i'm at the party i get invited upstairs
with a friend of mine
and he says come upstairs and they go
upstairs and when they go upstairs
he says i've been watching you guys
great awesome i'm thinking about putting
you guys in a movie
it's like great i'm finally being found
he says i'm at my prime i'm like 22 23.
he says but before we do anything i want
to see you guys kiss each other oh
okay and two dudes two dudes once you
kiss each other
so the other guy is his best friend he's
like
listen bro i'm willing to do the view
we're best friends here bro blood
brothers
and take it to our grave and my friend
was a tough guy says
hell no you're out of your mind what are
you talking about
probably gonna make it he says come on
he says now i'm out of here he says from
that he says my
friend stayed in the room i left the
party my friend ended up having a career
in hollywood nothing ever happened to me
okay what happened with the friend i was
like i have no idea what happened
but you got look i'm not going to say
names for them i'm just giving first
name on one of them
but this took off so here's the story
okay now let's let's put everything
there was i there
no could that be an absolute lie yes
could it be a uh story made up 100
but if that story is told by 200 other
men i think we ought to give a little
credibility
smoke fire to something that's going on
there so all i'm saying is
you know to to categorize th there there
are certain words that are being thrown
around right now hey bitcoin is a scam
no it's not it is a tool right hey
such and such is a scam for i used to
sell a lot you sell life insurance right
hey insurance is scam they never pay up
who says they never pay up well you have
to go read up to see if they never paid
up
the truth is yes many insurance
companies pnc
didn't pay up they will spend so much
money to not pay what
the claim that's there's a business to
not paying a claim on the pnc side do
you know today on the life insurance
side here
no not on life insurance exactly however
check this out i had a friend of mine
that um
had a quarter million dollar policy he
died when he died they investigated they
never paid him the policy
when it came back they said the the
autopsy the the testing that they did
they spent six months investigating this
they found that that the urine was used
was his brothers he was a smoker he used
his brother's urine they never paid on
the policy because he used somebody
else's urine to come out preferred
versus a smoker on the origination on
the origination policy because it was
that's fraud so in contestability class
they never paid it i get it do you know
how much you should did he died within
two years
he died within two weeks oh so the
two-year contestant i get it i totally
get it check this out
do you know how much insurance is right
now claims that have not been taken
and not have been called to insurance
carriers meaning someone died they had
coverage
but no one knew about it and that money
is still with the insurance plan
you know what's gotta be in the building
22. give it away 22 billion 22 billion
sitting there sitting there they just
need a death certificate to get a half a
million to get a million to get a
quarterly so look so somebody says well
insurance companies this no
there is the part that they fight claims
but you know the
the conspiracy side everything today if
you say something somebody disagrees
with you it's
that's what i mean by because i'm not
talking about the guys that spout stuff
over and over and over again it's like
dude
chill out relax a little bit right don't
just take everything as a hundred
percent the way i see it is
you give me a claim i say you know what
i don't know
let's look it up what do you think what
do you think what do you think and we
kind of go through it so
i don't know what happened here with our
friend john yeah it just sounds a little
too fishy man
that's all it is oh god this is like
this is like epstein
yeah that's exactly what i'm thinking
right this is a little too let me bring
you a different perspective here
you know we talk about the pros and cons
of social media
you know what social media we're in the
digital social media business it's good
like the fact that we're all just able
to sit here
on a podcast and give our opinions and
obviously there's some credence and
credibility
what they're going to do with this
footage right now well touche yes but
the reverse ended speaking of conspiracy
theories
and you talked about opinions is now
everyone can just get on their phone and
give you their opinion
and you know the cat's out the bag
like anyone can say anything and
anything can go down any rabbit hole at
this point
you know you could be a one person with
one follower
and just start tweeting stuff and
someone else sees it next thing you know
i heard a guy say
it's a slippery slope out there by the
way you're hiding behind everyone's got
power by the way you're not yourself
you're hiding behind the veil of
anonymity keyboard warriors you're start
some stuff
and you would never say these things to
people to their faces
oh my god ever and and by the way you
know what's a scary thing about going
down the rabbit hole of conspiracy
so i have family members who will tell
me no this is happening
look at no this is happening no this is
happening i am naturally so flippant
skeptical
okay i'm so skeptical with everything
that
that's why i'm a technically i want to
find out i want to do research tell me
did that really happen i don't know
about that i don't believe that i want
to v i want to verify right
yeah there are people who want to
believe
a hundred percent of things that agrees
with their base meaning so you're an
enemy and she tells me a bad thing about
you whether it's true or not i
want to believe it because it makes me
say that you are really a bad person
it's affirming patrick's bias that's a
problem and we have a lot of that in
america on both sides
we posted something on valuetainment
instagram the other day it was a picture
it was basically everyone getting in
line and you had two options
and one was the line for the
uncomfortable truth yeah and the other
line
was for you know fantasyland yeah and
like
a hundred people were in line yeah for
confirmation
and nobody wanted the uncomfortable
truth okay you probably could pull that
up on you know what happened with it on
our instagram is that the one that you
what it was just a picture of an image
it told a big story huh
he posted a picture of albert einstein
on instagram they took it down they said
this is not good uh what was this
they said it wasn't true they said it
wasn't true you know how they would
censor
especially like false covet claims yeah
like that they they did that for
the albert einstein quote that said like
uh if you judge a fish based on how he
can climb a tree
that that was the post where they were
kind of giving so what's untrue about
that
i guess either it wasn't his quote or
yes
so einstein didn't say that that's the
the quote police so now they're on the
literal
you know literacy literary lincoln
lincoln once said don't believe
everything you read on the internet
[Laughter]
by the way youtube we're joking we're
joking this is a joke we're just
joking there was no twitter when lincoln
wasn't live
it's not serious lincoln did not tweet
whoever's sitting there just watching
what we're doing
we're seriously joking so i'm i'm i'm a
clinically hyperactive person okay
this is decaf just put that out there no
you do not want to see me on caffeine
i took two and a half years out of my
life to write a book
because the conspiracy theories about
the federal reserve
were so wrong but at the same time it
was an even worse
organization than the conspiracy
theorist made it out to be i'm like no
no no you got this all wrong so that
that's how
deeply i feel fed up that's how deeply i
feel about
debunking conspiracies is that you get a
clinically hyperactive person to spend
two and a half years
documenting mainly i love that mainly
how dangerous i love the amazon so
people can't see the picture so
we're talking about janet yellen being a
dangerous person tell me why
and well she she would go up in front of
congress and she would say i really
didn't understand all that off-balance
sheet
i didn't understand what led up to the
financial crisis i didn't understand
what was happening on bank balance
sheets and i'm like
this is the woman that was that's our
new treasury secretary seriously
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]